Vivek Bald: Charisse is an
associate professor of
Communications at the SI
Newhouse School of Public
Communications at Syracuse
University. She holds bs degrees
in brain and cognitive science
and comparative media studies
from MIT.
I am assuming that you were one
of the earliest majors,
undergrad majors and CMS.
Technically, my degree says
humanities because CMS was not
yet a labeled major. So I do
have a Bachelors of Science in
humanities from MIT. It's a very
proud piece of paper I keep on
my wall.
So you were ahead of your time.
There was, I think, four of us
who graduated in my semester,
one of which is in our
attendees.
Charisse L’Pree: But yeah,
there's only Yeah, there's only
four of us who graduated last
semester.
Unknown: I think it became a
named major two years undergrad,
Major, two years laters maybe
2005.
Vivek Bald: Wow, great. Well,
um,
so then Charisse went on. To get
a master's degree from the
School of Cinematic Arts and a
PhD in social psychology from
the University of Southern
California. Charisse's work
focuses on how media affects the
way we think about ourselves,
and others, as well as how we
use media to construct and
reaffirm positive identities.
Her most recent book, 20th
Century Media and the American
psyche, about which she'll be
speaking today investigates
changes to the communication
environment over the past 150
years, and how these rapid yet
pervasive shifts have affected
our psychology at Syracuse
University. Charisse teaches
classes on communication and
diversity to professional media
students, specifically how to do
media. How do media affect our
understanding of different
social categories? And how do
the social categories of media
producers affect the media with
which we all engage? She has
mentored over 50 McNair Scholars
across disciplines at the
University of Southern
California, Loyola Marymount
University, and Syracuse
University since 2008, and was
awarded Teacher of the Year from
the Newhouse graduating class of
2017.
So welcome, or welcome back.
Charisse L’Pree: Thank you. It's
very exciting to be here. I feel
like my face a little red.
Comparative Media Studies and
frankly, MIT in general,
And since then, like my overall
goal in leaving or at that time,
you know, 18 years ago, this
dream can now draw this dream
can almost vote was to make
media better to make to improve
the media environment. And I
feel like I've really had that
opportunity specifically with
teaching critical thinking
skills to media producers. So I
knew how students can't major in
theory, they major in
Unknown: broadcast journalism,
newspaper, journalism,
advertising, PR, television,
radio, film, or like photography
and multimedia design. So by
imparting these skills to people
who are actually going out and
making media and affecting the
discourse, I feel like I'm
really having a direct impact on
the quality of media, and
fostering producers that can
create content that is
disruptive, and encourages other
people to meet more deeply about
media and the world in which
they live. So that's it. So
that's, that's kind of I don't
know if that's an introduction,
but it's a real context for what
I've been doing over the past 18
years. And for, and I assume
everyone to read the scan took a
listen, that was thoroughly
enjoyable. So out of curiosity,
quick show of hands, how many of
you listened to the thing? Okay,
cool. And how many of you read
it? Okay, a few other few
different ones. Okay, cool.
Thank you. I'm really curious as
to the experiential difference
in these spaces around. In this
case, audio, only media versus
visual media, I feel like I make
the argument in the third,
second chapter, second chapter,
section one, on the role of the
power of audio, to enact enable,
activate feelings of presence,
and the way in which we have
become so accustomed to having,
for example, our favorite
musician, in our home, in our
bed in our shower with us in the
car, right, singing just to us,
technically, they're singing to
a whole bunch of people, but
they're singing just for us. And
that,
that personal intimacy that
comes with audio media is,
frankly, 150 years old, and yet
it has become so normalized. So
it was a delight to read that
and create that content and
thinking, well, this is for
everyone, but knowing that
people would be listening to it
by themselves. So you know, you
spend so much time writing a
book and putting all your words
into happy little text, and then
to suddenly hear yourself talk
through it is, it was really
striking and kind of an
embodiment of the claims that I
make in the book in the first
place. But I did get an email
from a buddy of mine who's
reading it was like, reading
this book is awesome, it feels
like I'm in a conversation with
you. And so, you know, being
able to actually bring that to
fruition through the power of
recorded audio, I talked about
recorded music, but in the power
of recorded audio, was a
delightful opportunity. So, um,
well, what I had promised to you
today in the talk was to kind of
talk a little bit about the
book, but also to chart this
sort of cross methodological
journey. And so I use the term
cross methodological, more than
mixed methods. because
traditionally speaking, when we
say mixed methods, we're saying,
you know, I'm doing a study here
in this fashion, in this
fashion, and in this fashion,
and combining multiple
methodologies into one larger
setting. When I say cross
methodology, I literally mean,
well, what did we learn from
this method? And how can we
combine this method with this
other method to get at a more
nuanced explanation of some
global or psychological or media
phenomenon? And I will say, you
know, I feel like it's an
absolute privilege to be able to
do that, especially when we talk
about academia that's so
desperately siloed. Right? That
if your methods don't fit into
the methods that have been done,
that may work against you later.
So I put that out there that
it's very much a privilege that
I've had the opportunity to do
this and I've had
Charisse L’Pree: advisors,
including Professor Ravel, I've
had advisors
the kind of like my current
stuff, and it's kind of cross
methodological approaches. And
then I could talk a little bit
about what is media
psychogeography is and the goals
of the book itself. And then I'm
happy and excited to talk about
your research. Like I said, like
Professor ball said, I am. I've
mentored dozens of McNair
Scholars. McNair Scholars. I
don't know if anybody know what
a McNair Scholar is. Okay.
McNair. So McNair is the Ronald
E. McNair program. We don't have
one at MIT, which is fine. It'll
become ironic. As soon as I tell
you why. Ronald E. McNair was a
PhD graduate from MIT, first
black man in outer space.
It was not George Clinton, or
Sun Ra. Don't worry about those
are jokes at the expense of
afrofuturism. So yeah, first
black men in outer space. And he
died on the challenger. And so
it's a federally funded program
to encourage students of color
first gen college students, low
income students to pursue PhDs
and pursue research. So I've had
the privilege of working with
literally dozens of students who
are
Unknown: not generationally
familiar with the phenomenon of
research, but are very excited
about it. And what I've noticed
in these conversations is this
eagerness to answer questions
that have come through their
mind through through their lives
come through their eyes, in
unique ways, but also a general
frustration with the structure
of,
of what is traditional research,
right? So I've spent a lot of
time talking students through,
you know, sociology, students,
history students, media,
students, psych students,
business students, engineering
students, through ways in which
to answer the questions that
plague them in ways that will
fit into simultaneously the
expectations of academia and to
fulfill their own to seek out
the answers that they find most
fulfilling.
Charisse L’Pree: I will say, and
I talked about this in the book,
you know, like, just those early
observations that first time
when I had a real epiphany about
media biases, when I realized
that little boys were always the
ones who screamed, I won in game
commercials. And it's funny,
because they always have these
very diverse groups.
And so this willingness to think
differently and ask more
questions and not be satisfied
with the answers that you're
getting, I think are so
essential to life. And then when
we talk about media, as this is
Comparative Media Studies, the
extent to which we've been asked
not to question media is really
striking. Write that. And as
somebody who teaches media
students, now media producers,
asking why something is, is not
necessarily a good use of time,
when you need to turn out an
article in 24 hours, it's not a
good use of time, when you need
to turn out a news package in 12
hours, right media moves so
fast, that we're not allowed to
even stop and think more deeply
about it. And so that was part
of what brought me to this
exercise. Actually, before we
get to that, going through
Unknown: MIT, I was a core
seven, which is biology. And I
wanted to be a geneticist, I
went to all those nerd camps in
college like brown and Columbia,
and did genetics. And then I got
to organic chemistry, which was
512. And it kicked my butt.
Because organic chemistry is not
chemistry. It's physics. And I
suck at physics. So that
happened. I ended up dropping
out of school because I was in a
not a good position for a wide
variety of other reasons. I
actually started college, I
actually started MIT at 16.
wouldn't recommend it.
But not necessarily because 16
is inherently a bad number. But
my mother was very protective.
So when I went to college, it
was like the first freedom I
ever experienced. And it was it
was a lot there.
Charisse L’Pree: So anyway, I
end up dropping out of school
without real direction and work
suddenly becoming hard. And then
I had this epiphany with which
the whole book starts and I went
back and got degrees in Brain
and Cog and Media Studies. And
for me, I was always asking
questions across these two
disciplines. You know, using
brain and cog to think about
media, using media to think
about Brain and Cog. One of my
favorite course 9 papers I ever
wrote was for animal sex
behavior. And I don't remember
who taught the class I should
look that up. And I wrote a
paper on the multiple mating
habits of human beings, and
basically closed it with a
critical psychological
investigation of pimpin culture,
which was quite big at the time,
you know, 50 cent p i m p, Jay
Z, all those really big in, in
the pop culture and thinking
through how women are framed as
a commodity. Both in the animal
world The bigger your harem, the
you know, more impressive male
you are and applying that to
mediated culture. I got a C in
that class, but it is still my
favorite paper.
Unknown: So then, when I
graduated from MIT, I tried to
write a book called The media
made me crazy. It was gonna be a
critical autobiography about how
the media caused me such
emotional strife. I wrote up a
proposal I sent it David
Thorburn David Thorburn
responded and said it was the
most naive thing he'd ever read.
I broke down in tears, and
realized I need to learn how to
write. So I went and got a
Master's at USC, and critical,
critical studies in the School
of Cinematic Arts, and then a
PhD in the social psych
department. And again, I was
privileged to have advisors my
advisor was Steve Reed and Lynn
Miller, who's in Annenberg at
USC. Never tell me No. And even
though Steve's area, Steve
Reed's area was not media. He
was constantly just saying,
Okay, if that's the question you
want to ask, this is how we will
answer it from a psychological
perspective. And that was that
kind of support is what I tried
to bring, not just to the
students, but also to myself. So
this book now the psychology of
20th Century Media, or excuse
me, 20th Century Media in the
American psyche. The goal is
really to think about how these
new communication capacities,
the ability for us to be looking
at each other real time miles
apart, is remarkable. And
frankly, There's been a lot of
discussion about like how zou
popped off out of nowhere, but
now literally within a year,
since pandemic and we can talk
about how pandemic accelerated
everything. Zoom is now a verb,
right? It took Google at least
10 years to become a verb. Now,
it's, you know, we, we expect to
zoom. In fact, I think it wasn't
with press one, I was calling
somebody else. And we had a zoom
meeting, and I called him on his
phone. And he's like, oh, are we
doing this on the phone, I'm
like, yeah, I'm in the car,
we're doing this on the phone.
And like, just the idea of going
backwards in communication
strategies was so foreign,
right, we're always having
meetings, on the zoom. Now. I
also like to save the before
platforms, it makes me feel
delightfully old, like the
Facebook and the Twitter.
So really thinking through these
technologies that have become so
ingrained in our lives, the
phone, the ability to connect
with loved ones, and talk to
them in real time, across
distance, again, is frankly,
only about less than 100 years
old, when we start to look at
how quickly it was adopted, and
when it hits saturation, and so
on and so forth is less than 100
years old. But it just becomes
so normal to the point where my
three year old is like, yeah,
let's call so and so. Right. And
so I really wanted to think
about this, this historiography,
or to do a historiography. And
I'm probably using the term
incorrectly, but I really like
it, to do a historiography of
how media has impacted our
psychology over time. Because
psychologists for the most part
are so distanced from history,
they really like to say, you
know, this is what we do. This
is how we think, and kind of map
that onto how we have always
thought, but one of the
arguments I make in the
interview with Henry, I think
that was also shared is, so much
of psychology is based in people
like manipulations,
psychological manipulations, are
based in media usage. So reading
a passage and then manipulating
this passage to feature one name
or another different argument,
showing you a picture, right,
all of that has become so
normalized. But literally 150
years ago, literacy was way, way
down. And we didn't have
photorealistic pictures. So
everything that we measure in
psychology is largely based in a
world that we have forgot, is
based in today. And we've kind
of forgotten about what happened
before the world we live in
today existed. And so that was
always very troubling to me. And
especially as we talked about it
with media, you know, that
communication, specifically
communication technologies, in
this case, mass media, for the
most part, media that
disseminate mass messages are,
there's so new, they're very
new, we talked about just a
blink in the human eye, and you
know, human history, they're
new. And yet they're so normal.
And so it was a delight to sit
down and kind of collate all of
this research in a
conversational way to think, you
know, how do these technologies
actually impact us? And change
how we engage with the world?
And how have they done that so
remarkably, in such little time?
So I'll just say, and then I can
pause or stop. I don't want I
want to answer questions like I
want to make myself available
and hear about the work you guys
are doing. Y'all are doing read
somewhere else like oh, y'all is
a much better term, you guys.
Let's see here. Oh, hold on.
Let's see. Sure. So as we think
about this, I'll just hit a
couple quick slides.
Charisse L’Pree: When we talk
about a media psychography, I'm
talking about the examination of
how the collective psyche
impacts and has been impacted by
media psychologies,
Unknown: by media technologies.
So literally looking to our own
history with media, how did you
come to understand yourself
through the communication
technologies that have become
available to you over your
lifetime? It's very easy for us
to talk about how writing or
reading impacted us. But we
often don't think about the
other dimensions, the other
technological affordances. So by
looking to our own histories
with media rather than
succumbing to the allure of
newness, I think this is right
out of the intro, we can further
unpack relationships that users
develop with media and provide
insight into how people might
build future mediated
relationships. So this whole
book also is rooted in a class
that I teach called psychology
of interactive media. ask
students to production students
to think upstream about why
people use media so that we can
anticipate what people might do
downstream. And I'll just, I'll
close with that. I'll stop
talking with this one. I can
also show you my lovely little,
actually got a couple a couple
more.
Let's see.
Um, I'll just all come here
that, yeah, I had a whole order,
and then I'm not using it. So I
apologize, I will say. So for
those of you who read it, I
didn't technically include the
images or describe them. So
that's on me. But this is also
basically my argumentation, that
we have a new technology that's
developed. This technology
enables novel strategies for
communication, widespread
adoption of the technology, then
those novel communication
strategies become social norms,
social norms, change culture,
customs and institutions. And
then we demand new communication
strategies which relate to new
technological development.
I will say as we think about as
we think about and I'll close
with this slide,
as we think about oh, this is
terrible. Alright, well, it's
just a very small, so I
apologize. As we think about the
different ways. media can be
conceptualized, I can't I argued
for this fit taxonomy. Let me
see if I
get a better picture.
That's not working anymore. No,
okay, I'm gonna get a better
picture perception.
Just missing.
As we think about technologies,
we can start to break them down
into different structures. So
what I'm going to do is
actually, I'm just going to zoom
in here and then blow this up
for you. I apologize again, for
not having a better image.
Okay, so that we have a format.
It's non visual audio, static
text, static images, synchronize
video and interactive video, and
whether that's delivered in
analog electronic formats or
digital formats. And then we get
into industry and content
journalism, advertising,
entertainment, and peer to peer.
So we see in this graph in this
image, we see that the gray
areas are basically areas where
there is no research on the
impact of race and gender in
those dimensions in those media
platforms. And so we start to
see when we think about media
differently, where the questions
have been answered and where
they have not. And I think that
that's a really important
component for any media scholar
to consider is, what questions
have been answered. But more
importantly, which questions
were we unable to even consider
because we weren't thinking
about media in this format. So I
can stop here, this probably
seems like a good place to stop,
I could also walk you through
the outline of the book and the
different claims that I make in
the three different sections
intimacy, regularity, and
reciprocity. Very briefly, I'll
show you this, this happy little
graph, which is what I presented
at MIT 10 when Andrew and I met
in 2019. But basically, I make
the argument that intimate media
like theatrical film recorded
music and consumer market
cameras, as well as regular
media. So media that is
integrated into our daily lives,
like radio network television
and cable television, and
reciprocal media. So media that
responds to our actions like
magnetic tape, video gaming, and
dial up, ISP is
Charisse L’Pree: all impact 21st
century media practices. And we
can only see how they do that by
spending more time with media
that we effectively now called
defunct.
Unknown: Let's start with that.
I like the word default. So I'll
happily pause here, stop here.
and invite questions, thoughts
here a little bit about your
research. Or we can keep talking
so I'll throw to Professor ball
to to moderate from here. Thanks
for letting me tell my story
though.
Vivek Bald: Thank you. I wanted
to just ask with regard to you
in the introduction, you you
talk about you know the this
historical process of of, you
know, of groups of people
becoming accustomed to
particular particular forms of
interaction around particular
forms of media that then that
then conditioned the way that we
understand and use initially new
forms of media. And there's
there's sort of a back and forth
between what your, what you're
describing as, as new and what
you're describing, as as old.
Right? That there's not a not a
clear break, but this this kind
of, ongoing process of, or
cycles of adaptation and change.
And so I just wanted to ask if
you could talk a little bit
about this, the tension between
sameness and newness, right,
that that sort of appears in, in
what you're describing? And
there's, there's sort of a
follow up question to about
about generations. But but we
can get to that in a second.
Unknown: Okay, cool. So I was
about to start writing down your
questions. Once you get into two
parts, I'm like, I'm gonna write
that one down. So same, same,
but different, and I think is
one of my favorite averages that
somebody said, I think is on
because traveling with some
Aussies, and they kept saying
same same but different. You
know, I think was Brits Same,
same, but different. So I will
say, and one of the points that
I make is I only ever use new
and old as relative terms,
right? One media is newer, in
the grand timeline of things
than some other medium. I try
not to categorize media as new.
But at the same time,
Charisse L’Pree: new
technologies, rhetorically
speaking, we use new
technologies as an easier way to
fulfill old habits, right, so
[...], New Media engaged with
old brains, that we use new
media to fulfill old habits. So
when the cell phone was the cell
phone, it was a phone. And like,
we got to use a phone wherever
we wanted to use this phone. And
then we learned that there was
this thing called text
messaging. And Americans were
way late on that game, right? We
were so consumed with using the
phone as a phone.
Unknown: And now we don't even
use the phone as a phone
anymore. Because these these
other opportunities, email,
social media, video games, all
of those things, become the
dominant use of the computer in
our pocket, even though we still
technically call it a phone. So
I think that to come back to
what I was starting to write is
the tension between the idea of
sameness and different is that
we, and this is the claim I make
about it being in a relationship
with media, we lead in every, in
every new relationship, we
expect to at the very least have
all the good things that we had
from the last relationship. And
so that's, that's the baggage we
bring to every new relationship.
And I probably shouldn't use
baggage. So flippantly, but you
know, that's the baggage we
bring to every new relationship
is the joys and fears of our
last relationship. And I argue
that if we think about media
technology in that relational
lens, what is the baggage that
we're bringing to every new
relationship? And how does that
impede us frequently from being
able to see the potential
everything in this new
relationship that could happen?
When in reality, we're looking
at this new relationship through
the lens of our old
relationships? And if we map
that on to media, how are we
looking at this new,
temporarily, temporarily, right,
time wise, new media medium,
through the baggage of our old
mediums. And I think that that
baggage of our old mediums is
not just how we engage with it
technology, but it becomes a way
of understanding ourselves,
right? There's what you bring to
every new relationship is a
residual from the old
relationship, but it's a
residual of the old
relationship, because it still
resides within you. And so
that's basically the argument
that I'm trying to make that
with every new technology, the
only constant is us. And in that
constant, but that constant
itself has been evolving,
because we have all been moving
through these technologies,
arguably together. For as I
argue, in this case, 150 years
and earlier, that answer your
question.
Vivek Bald: Yeah, and it kind of
it connects somewhat to the
second part. We Is that that,
you know, also in the
introduction, you you speak
about you draw a distinction
between different regions of the
world, for example, that are
differently resource that have
different motive are amounts of
access to different kinds of
technologies. And you draw a
distinction in terms of the
being able to sort of make make
statements about the
psychological relationship to
media in one place based upon
another. Right. You sort of
cautioned against that, right.
What what I was curious about in
reading that, and thinking about
the, like, aspects of
generational change is, is that,
you know, what you're describing
in terms of, you know, bringing
the baggage of our past media
use to each new medium, of
course, generationally, there
will be, you know, folks younger
than us whose engagement with
with the new media is actually
their originary engagement.
Right. to, to the extent that,
in some ways, you might argue
that the generational
differences might start to look
more like the kinds of
geographic distance differences
that you are, are speaking about
as well. And I was wondering,
you know, about, about that, or,
you know, what can we say about?
You know, is there a kind of
essentially different
psychological engagement with
technology from
one generation to another?
Charisse L’Pree: I mean, I would
say, Yes, I will say, I'll make
a point that, I do caution
against generalizing a small
sample, right, because I, ever
since I read that weird article
from Heinrich at all, Heinrich,
something and Nora [...].
Unknown: I apologize for
forgetting the second author,
but that weird article about
social science, and that is that
social science researchers look
at Western educated,
industrialized, rich, democratic
nations, and that and then they
go and say, Oh, this is
generalizable to everybody.
Like, as somebody who has
largely been outside of the
intersectional space that is
generalized. And as somebody who
has been taught to study those
who are in that intersectional
space, I'm very salient. It's
very salient to me about what I
should and should not be
generalizing to, by which I mean
to say, I've definitely had
reviewers asked me where my
white control is, right? Why
don't you have a white control
when I'm doing research
literally on black and Latino
populations. I've looked at my
own datasets and just seen
dominance of white women, in the
case of psych research, that are
at private institutions studying
college, right, like this sample
is so narrow, so I'm just always
very hesitant of saying that
this is generalizable to
everyone. At the same time, the
whole book is called the
American psyche, right? Having
said that, I try to acknowledge
my own generational
situatedness. Like in the very
first paragraph, this is where I
am. And I tried not to include
it just in the interest of, you
know, privacy. But I do talk
about it in the third part with
Henry about watching my own
child, engage. And like my
husband, and I was five years
older than I am, right. And
that's when I are sitting here
just like watching him, come up
on the Alexa and be like, Alexa,
I want this song, and Alexa just
plays it, I will have you know
that he has now discovered Who
let the dogs out. And so that is
playing on loop in our house,
which is not cool. And in case
you don't know about it, that
song is totally about sex. And
it makes me very uncomfortable.
But he loves it. And you know,
it's it's just remarkable to
watch his desires be met
immediately. And us know that
when we were his age, the only
desire that could be met
immediately was probably the
book that was on the floor.
Right But he his infinite
desires are met immediately and
he will grow up with and we're
just trying to instill you know,
some level of delayed
gratification. I've just heard
I've run them through the
marshmallow test every few days.
But because everything is so
immediate to him, I can't even
begin to think about what his
generation will be like when it
comes to this expectation of on
demand. Like, we came into on
demand culture, we came to
understand it as adults, we're
like, oh, I can watch this now.
Instead, this new generation is
like, I should be able to watch
this. Now, I'm guaranteed to
watch this now, how dare you not
let me watch this now? And I'm,
I'm fascinated by it. I do think
that generational differences
because of the speed at which
things advance do have the power
to become divisions on par with
geographical distances and
geographical distances seem to
be collapsing. Right. So our
understanding of different
groups of people and what we
have known groups of people to
be geographically disparate, for
example. What's his name? Is it
Friedman, who wrote the world is
flat, right? That the
geographical distances have
fallen, have become less
impactful, less impactful, still
less impactful, whereas the
generational differences become
striking. And it is left up to
us, you know, a generation
coming into content to move
faster, because the generation
born into the content, right,
what is it? digital natives,
that the phrase they use, are
and that's got all sorts of
problems unto itself. But let's
keep going for now. Like, their
expectation of what is normal in
the world, is something that we
have to learn to be normal. And
I think that
i think that that difference has
the power to have some really
interesting and important
intergenerational conversations
and connections, it just doesn't
seem as evident when you're, you
know, when your child can do
more on your iPad that you can.
Vivek Bald: Um, well, let me let
me open things up to questions
from our students or from, from
our attendees via the q&a.
Unknown: I'll also while we
think about it, I'll just go
ahead and just describe, just
give you a little bit of some of
the research that I've done most
recently, very briefly. So my
research interests fall across
representation of groups in
media content, using media to
construct identity and disrupt
discourse and testing the
potential of technology. And
these are some of the pubs and
auto ethnographic textual
analysis of all American Girl,
qualitative analysis of
Caribbean, multiracial Caribbean
and how they use social media,
satirical education, or
educational satire, learning and
laughing on Last Week Tonight,
I'm actually working on a
textbook right now on satire and
diversity. So that's pretty
interesting. content analysis of
early youth created music videos
on YouTube. avoidant engagement,
which is a collection of
quantitative studies arguing for
a theoretical and practical
model of interactivity and
persuasion. So basically, what
happens when you can skip ads,
it makes you like the platform
more and hate the brand, like
the platform and hate the brand.
And then this is a fun little
cross section, we look at a
qualitative, quantitative or
critical. So these are just some
of the things I've been working
on over the past couple years,
and the diversity of research
questions. But in the end, all
of them are to get at the same
question, which is to talk about
your slip of the tongue at the
beginning. How do we media,
right, how to media how do we
media? So I was still readable.
Awesome. I think that was my I'm
sorry, I'm bad with chats. That
was my table from Forever Ago.
Thank you, Andre. questions,
thoughts? Angry rejections of my
theory. I want to go Tomas, can
you pronounce your name for me?
Tomás Guarna: Um, and yeah, the
question was around that about
the pronunciation. So, um, so
something that we've been
thinking about lately in in the
department, we have a small
reading group that's concerned
with letting American media
studies just reading media
studies from Latin America, and
understanding how these
traditional media studies kind
of goes with all that America
studies with understanding
cultural studies, that kind of
stuff. And I think I understand
your work goes in its
directions, right? You address
terms of Latina Latina x media,
and the things that I think the
last few years are getting more
and more attention. And I was
wondering if you could give some
insights on whether on road you
see that going, if you think
there's a How do you approach
understanding Latino audiences?
And maybe if we were thinking
about what advice you could give
to students, we're approaching
this topic maybe?
Unknown: Sure. Thank you. I will
say that. My expertise is in
processes of subgroup media. So
I will I will outright say that
my expertise is not in Latin x
media. I do look at subgroups
specific and how subgroups use
media. So if we were talking
about how observations of Latin
x people in the United States
I'm not going to talk about in
Latin America, because I will
not be able, that's not my
expertise. And I hope that my
perspective and methodology
inspire you to ask similar
questions around different media
practices. I think a big piece
of how we're talking about it. I
will also say so I do have work
on multiracial Caribbean's, but
my family is British Caribbean,
I'm British guy knees. So it's
always funny people like, oh,
you're from South America, so
you must speak Spanish and like,
No, you don't. You've missed
some points here. That it's a
much more complicated thing,
then you've come from this
geographic region, therefore,
you must be this. But and I
think that that sentiment is
still very much is. In my
observations, I think that
sentiment is very much pervasive
in New Media discussions, new
media's and digital social
media, user generated content in
the subgroups, any given
subgroup where they're demanding
people to think differently
about their existence. And
that's what we're talking about
Latin x media in the United
States, where many of these that
have been marginalized for such
a long time. The content that
I'm observing is very much about
pushing back on faulty
understandings of a group. So I
think that the question needs to
be divided between what happens
with Latin x media, where Latin
x is a numerical minority, and I
put their culture on that, and
we can get into that and
changing numbers and so on and
so forth. But where it has been
either a numerical minority or
historically marginalized group,
and how we see media being used
to talk back to these norms,
both for people who have
internalized those norms, like
remember, that stereotype you
saw on television, isn't you?
And to people who are not part
of this group, right? That
there's a very complicated
question there. And I look
forward to your work if you're
doing research on Latin x
populations in Latin x media in
Latin America. how those voice
what voices have not
historically been heard, and how
one of the papers that I have is
on target versus total
marketing, and basically the
oxymoron of the total market,
that inevitably we have this
idea that we are all x, whatever
x is, but at the same time,
we're constantly pursuing this
individuated conversation. So I
look forward to hearing about
how media technologies are used
to tell which stories and which
stories are getting more
coverage
in,
Charisse L’Pree: in any given
community and population. So the
answer your question is
Tomás Guarna: yeah, and
definitely some issues that
we're we're speaking about, and
it's a small group that with
that might have questions was
also years ago, grad students,
and gave us also all things
here, too. But yeah, we're
definitely talking about this
issues about also what it means
to be that to America and Latina
x, and what maybe the ideas of
globalization or presentation
mean there. So definitely, thank
you for the answer.
Charisse L’Pree: Absolutely. And
I would also always, always
invite you that every theory
that you read, regardless of who
wrote it, ask yourself what does
this mean for our population?
And what does this mean our
population of interest, right?
Our population of interest and
our media, does it fit? Does it
not fit? And if it doesn't fit,
how does the theory need to
evolve? And that is the voice
that I'm very excited to hear
from you.
Whoo. Yes Professor Ravel?
Jeff Ravel: Hi, Charisse great
talk. Thank you.
I'd like to hear more about your
critical research on Romeo and
Juliet. Could you share that
with us?
Charisse L’Pree: I would thank
you. I research is a big word.
American and human values,
right, very much a Richard Dyer
star study, classic celebrity
star study. So then we were
stuck like, well, what are we
going to do next? Well, we
wanted to do something that's a
bit more feminine, because we
had done fast and furious, very
masculine. And we do talk about
Keanu Reeves playing with gender
roles, but it's still kind of
masculine dominated. And so that
brought us to
how the choices of the writer
and director as well as the
cultural time, right what's
happening in the culture at the
time, infuse and change and
reflect the story. Because Romeo
and Juliet is such a, it's such
a go to that anybody can layer
something on to it. So we start
with Romeo and Juliet. We start
with West Side Story. And then
we do the Zeffirelli. Right. So
these two very early ones.
Definitely is very true to the
narrative, and it's generally
critically acclaimed, then we
jump ahead and do Romeo and
Juliet. I don't know if anybody
is familiar with trauma films,
but they are Toxic Avenger, like
grossed-out B movie, really
inappropriate stuff like incest
and mutilation and basically all
the stuff that made Shakespeare
great. That's the tagline of the
film. But then thinking through
how this kind of grows out punk
culture of 1996, directed by
James Gunn, by the way of Marvel
fame,
Unknown: We did Shakespeare in
Love. We did gnomeo and Juliet,
we did Private Romeo. So if you
haven't seen Private Romeo, it's
also an independent film.
But it was shot basically it was
released three months before
don't ask don't tell is
repealed. So it's shot in the
midst of Don't Ask Don't Tell
and features to boys, two young
men in a boy's Military Academy,
falling in love while
simultaneously performing the
play. So at any time given time,
you're starting to see how the
play itself is simultaneously
work in the classroom and like
trying to understand this
language, but also very much
intimate and lived through this
young love. So that was great.
We also watched David and Fatuma
which I was very honored to be
able to expose that to Bob for
the first time, he never knew
that film. And it's basically
Israeli Palestine in Romeo and
Juliet, in Jerusalem, starring
Martin Landau, Martin Landau,
his last film along with Tony
Curtis, his last film. So it's,
it's really weird, but it's it's
fascinating and just looking at
how this story has been retold
over and over and over again.
And I'm trying to remember who
the the character from Gossip
Girl. He's British, and he plays
like the evil one I can't
remember. Anyway, he plays
Tybalt in the 2013 version, and
in an interview, he said, the
thing about Romeo and Juliet is
that every generation deserves
their own. So we take that
language and start looking at
how are we telling generational
stories through this story that
we all know. And it has been a
joy, and thank you for asking.
Tomás Guarna: So you know,
Unknown: like, comment,
subscribe, you can find it at
critical incurious.com. I'm
about to release episode nine,
which is Shakespeare in Love.
And then Episode 10, which is
gnomeo, and Juliet. And then we
close with the 2013, and Romeo
and Juliet in Harlem. If you
haven't seen that one, that's
the first one it was sold as you
know, advertise as the first all
cast of color to do Romeo and
Juliet. So they're all the who's
doing a Romeo and Juliet remix?
Anybody, everybody, please get
to it. Give me more.
Vivek Bald: We have a question
from the QA. Yes, couple of
them, actually.
So this is from Hamidreza
Nasiri.
Hello, and thanks for the talk.
In that chart that is also on
page nine, where you consider
the evolving interaction between
top down and bottom up norm
setting. So for example, Twitter
first started to adopt hashtags
in a systematic, systematic way,
after Iran's 2009 protests, and
then leader in the protests in
Arab countries, and that change
the structure as well as the use
of Twitter. And also the whole
adoption of hashtag, even in our
everyday conversations of
interaction is especially more
powerful in the new interactive
media. As for example, the norms
of filmmaking were mostly set by
a few studios in a more top down
manner. As a result, the norms
of filmmaking have also changed
and evolved very slowly. And
actually, mostly unchanged since
then. But the norms of new media
and hence our communication is
evolving faster, due to this
constant two way interaction.
Charisse L’Pree: Yes.
Unknown: Yeah, no, I completely
agree. And again, I think the
accelerated speed at which we
see things change are is
essential. Like we have to
acknowledge that what is current
today will not be current
tomorrow, and that that level of
evolution is not, is new, it's
definitely new. I will also say
it's funny that you bring up
film because one of the papers,
that is it's in a book called
mediated millennials, and
looking at how youth generated
music videos, and from 2007 and
2013. And looking at how in
2007, it was very much adopting
tropes from film and kids were
just trying to like remake their
favorite music videos. But then
by 2013, we see this real
emphasis on kind of
individualized and selfie
culture, which was not
necessary, which then like,
wrapped into the music videos
that were being made at the
mainstream level. So two, things
advanced quickly, because they
can be shared in my opinion, can
be shared so quickly, right? So
you have that back and forth.
And now you see that older
mediums, desperate to survive or
mining whatever the young people
are doing, in hopes that that
will bring them into the
theater. I think it really comes
down to institutionalization
right film was institutionalized
before it was required to
change. I had 35 years before
television came along and
intelligence, like, we're taking
this good luck. And then film
was forced to change, as opposed
to other technologies, as
opposed to like Twitter and
Social Media. Their
institutional power just comes
from the number of users they
have, in my opinion, you know,
and the fact that they've got
whatever, hundreds of engineers
that can turn around a new, a
new skin, like every six months,
stop at Facebook, just stop it.
Sorry. Thank you.
Charisse L’Pree: Kelly has had
that for a while and so did
Ambar. I believe I'm pronouncing
this correctly. please correct
me if I'm wrong. Yeah.
Kelly Wagman: Thank you for the
talk. I was curious when you've
been thinking about
relationships with media. If
you've thought about people's
relationships with media that
talkback like robots, like how
do you think from a psychology
perspective, people should be
thinking about their
relationships was like that
level of interactive media?
Charisse L’Pree: Sure. And I
think before we even get to
robots we can talk about we can
I guess Alexa is a robot.
Unknown: We can talk about GPS,
right, we can talk about
reciprocal, and I would argue
that those are very much
reciprocal media. I love talking
about magnetic tape, right?
Because I push play and it goes
I pushed up and stops and like
that was I was I argue
unprecedented. At a mass level.
I think what's really similarly
with video games, I think, you
know, before we jump into what
was it, her she her with
Scarlett Johansson or this
Futurama episode where fry falls
in love with a robot? I think we
have to think about this nuanced
expectation of communication.
And the fact that I say go, and
it goes, I want something and it
gives it to me. The fact that
two things, you know, the fact
that we can have our emotions
immediately our needs, not
emotions, but our needs emotion
immediately gratified is
something that we have to
remember, like we have to be
conscious of it. And so I'm not
saying don't use robots. I'm
saying that robots are not
humans, Reeves. And NASS would
say we might forget. And
secondly, oh, crap, did I lose
it at such? Oh, I do talk about
the availability paradox. And
this idea that when the world is
at your fingertips, we don't
pursue it. Right? I track this
back to like cable news, right?
cable news channels are all
within the same, like 10 channel
spectrum, right? Like, if you go
up to channels, you go from
msnbc to Fox News. So you can
literally push a button and have
a completely worldview,
completely different worldview
presented to you, but we don't.
And I have so many students that
come into my office, like they
don't know what this word means.
I'm like, yo, you're literally
sitting with your phone. You all
you have to do is say Siri,
define this word. And it will
tell you that this word, but
instead, we're like, oh, just
there's just too much stuff.
It's just too much. So I would
argue that a we have to realize
that that responsiveness is is a
privilege, right, as opposed to
the norm as opposed to the
standard. But at the same time,
how are we using that
responsiveness to improve our
own lives? Or how are we
becoming a little bit lazy? By
not utilizing the full potential
coming back to potential
promising practice using the
full potential of a given
responsive technology? And in
the case of robots? I mean, do
we have robots that aren't
connected to the internet
anymore? I mean, I assume so.
But
this?
Yeah, the question comes down to
what does the robot do? What
does the robot do for you? And
why is that robot in your life?
And I would argue that that's
the same question we need to ask
for any technology. That is that
a good answer?
Kelly Wagman: Yeah, thank you.
Thank you, Ambar.
Ámbar Reyes: Yeah, thank you.
Well, mine is a little. Like,
it's about my thesis in my work.
So I don't know like if
everybody will want to hear it,
but here we go. So basically,
what I'm trying to do is like
comparing the way people create
their out of biographical
narratives, without biographical
biographies generated by
algorithms in social platforms.
Oh, yeah. So you But the thing
is, like, I don't have a
psychology background. And like
I am trying to think about,
like, you know, in psychology,
it has been recognized that the
formation of life narratives
plays a crucial role in the
construction construction of
personal identity, right. I was
like
I was wondering if you could
give me like an insight where to
look at like I saw your like,
what's your talk like your TED
talk? And you're like, anyone
health explores itself using
like different media. Or you see
how, like algorithmic narrative,
Charisse L’Pree: you're good
keep going?
Unknown: okay?
Ámbar Reyes: How can like
algorithmic narratives can be
used as a tool for reflection,
rather than a way in which like
machines and companies like
limit our reflectivity? So I
think you could give me a good
insight.
Charisse L’Pree: Well, I do
discuss in chapter three on
consumer market cameras, and
basically how consumer market
cameras allowed us to create our
own autobiographical visual
narratives easily, right, like I
push a button, I have a picture
of this moment, and I can line
them all up and create an
autobiography. And so I do talk
a little bit, you'll like that
chapter because it gives you a
little bit about the psychology
in how we construct memories
through visual images. And I do
explicitly talk about
algorithmic
Ámbar Reyes: Thank you.
Charisse L’Pree: Of course.
Vivek Bald: There's so there's
another question in the q&a
from Cory Schwaitzberg.
You argue in the chapter that we
should avoid overly determinist
understandings of how media
technologies influence human
behavior. For example, social
media makes you depressed.
Considering how interdependent
and convoluted psycho social and
technological effects are on
people slash users. That said
Facebook's business model is to
establish and strengthen
predictable profitable casual
relationships between data
targeted advertising and user
spending. You use the social
media platform to pursue
psychosocial needs. Facebook,
collects your data targets ads
to you, hopefully influences
your consumer behavior and makes
money makes money if they
succeed, incentivizing Facebook
book to optimize their social
media experience to make you
more useful as a data mine and
add consumer. How do you
reconcile the general idea that
technologies don't dictate
behavior with the fact that the
tech giants successfully
measured by multibillion dollar
profits, use AI scientists, data
analysis analysts and UX
researchers to deliberately
influence user behavior?
Charisse L’Pree: Okay, so very
quickly, two or three things I
want to say one, I don't think
they determine behavior, they
encourage behavior. And then
when we feel good about it
becomes a cycle unto itself,
right? So they're encouraging
this behavior, but at any given
point, you could turn it off,
right? We have that freewill.
You could delete Facebook and it
keeps going, like goes viral on
Facebook to delete Facebook. You
know it but it encourages this
behavior. And when that behavior
feels good, then we engage in
that behavior. So it is a cycle
in which the platform's create
one trigger. And then that
continues to spin on itself,
like some kind of
Unknown: technological cotton
candy. And it's sweet. I've
already gotten lost in this
metaphor, I'm really hungry. I'm
it's dinnertime. Um, so I think
it's not necessarily the
technology. But when we look at
it from an outside perspective,
it would appear that the
technology is determining our
behavior. But when we're in it,
we realize that we've only been
pushed in one direction, and we
keep going in that direction
because momentum. And then until
we see that we're being pushed
in that direction. We cannot
stop. The other thing I wanted
to mention regarding Keanu
Reeves is, you know, as you talk
about Facebook becoming a model
using human users, as a mind,
I'm automatically like thinking
about those shots from matrix
where the humans become the
battery from the robots, right.
And until we realize that we're
in this space, we cannot walk
away from it. And I would argue
that this is something I say
over and over and over again, if
social media is not meeting your
needs, if a given platform is
not meeting your needs, you got
to let it go. You gotta like
this, you have to. And it's,
it's easier said than done. I
will say I. So when I, when I
had my child, three years ago, I
started a new Instagram page for
him, because I didn't want to be
one of those people who's like
their baby just took over their
social media feed. And that's
not to crap on those people. I
just didn't want to be that
person. So I created a new
profile for him. And I post a
picture every day. So like, he's
got his own page. It's private.
We're not trying to make the
baby go viral, right? It's
private. It's only family and
friends. So we use a very
limited circle. And now I'm on
that one all the time, because
all it is is family, and like
Smithsonian Zoo pictures, and
Dolly Parton's imagination
library. And so regularly, I get
to the end of the internet, like
that's not a thing. You're never
supposed to get to the end of
the internet. That's the amazing
situation of infinite scrolling.
But I get to the end of the
internet all the time and
Instagrams, like you have
nothing new to look at, like,
great. Alright, so I would just
encourage, you know, we have to
be able to see how our behavior
is being manipulated. It's been
manipulated since you know,
newspaper newspapers, right,
this sensationalism, yellow
journalism, all of that stuff
was trying to foster outrage and
anger and policy change and
popular change. Through
encouraging it now. It's much
more interactive, it's almost
infinite. You know, it's just
accelerated, but those same,
that same willingness we have,
and I feel like I'm using
willingness wrong. So let me
just finish the sentence. That
same willingness are willing
acquiescence. And I do talk
about this willing acquiescence,
I tie back to the theatrical
film, like we willingly give
over our consciousness to
theatrical film, we sit in
there, we turn off our phones,
we separate ourselves from the
outside world, and we say to the
filmmaker to the screen, show me
what you want me to see. Is it
surprising that we would do that
for social media as well? That's
it, I got deep, I got deep. And
I feel like that's where I got
to end. Anything more. It's just
I'm only going to be repeating
myself.
Vivek Bald: Well, actually, I
wanted to just follow up on
that. And I think it connects
somewhat with the follow up
question that that's in the q&a.
And it is, you know, while I was
reading, I was thinking about
all of the the kind of public
conversation about, about the
2016 election and about just the
siloing of different sectors of
society through social media.
And I'm just curious to hear
your, your take on that kind of
conversation about like,
whether, you know, in some ways
it's similar to, you know, the,
I don't know if you remember the
organization that PMR sees that
was
Unknown: Oh, yeah, the parents
music resource coalition. We
watched that Zappa congressional
hearing in class.
Vivek Bald: Yes. So, um, you
know, is this is the
conversation around the the kind
of very dangerous fracturing and
polarization of society via
social media.
Is it
were their actual, potentially
very negative effects broadly in
society?
Charisse L’Pree: Well, just to
let you know, you guys all know
that to harken back to the pmrc.
Prince
Unknown: sex. You know that that
right? Like that's that's what
happened. And tipper gore was
angry about it, Prince invented
sex. I think that. So I do make
the argument about silos as it
relates to cable, because
usually when we're talking about
these siloing, and these echo
chambers, we're comparing them
to the three network system when
it was ABC, CBS, and NBC
providing all national content.
So when we had three outlets,
three television outlets, yeah,
you it was a consensus
conversation. But we're not
talking about, you know, the
hundreds of partisan papers that
were happening in 1700. And
there's a great visualization,
I'm happy to find it, I've got
it in there. And some of my
class notes about the rise and
fall of American newspapers. And
you start to see like how many
there were just like everybody
had a newspaper that was every
partisan perspective that they
wanted, between 17 118 100. And
then around 1800, they start to
homogenize, and like, what a
homogenized but you know,
aggregate into your big papers,
and then around like 2000, they
just start to die off. But it's
a really beautiful
visualization. And I think that
what's lost in this dots is that
each of those newspapers was a
unique perspective. And each of
them were warring against
another newspaper in a given
area. So when we see the
siloing, of communities, and I
was just participating in a
Reddit science panel on social
media, political ideology and
identity, that we see this
siloing rise and fall, when is
it going to fall? Again? I don't
know. I can't predict that. But
I think it's important to
realize that when we're talking
about partisanship, now, we're
comparing it to television,
we're comparing it to network
television, we're not comparing
it to cable television, which
you know, diversify the spectrum
to the point where people could
find whatever they wanted. We're
not comparing it to partisan
newspapers from the 18th
century. So I think that that
that historical lens is
important that we consistently
drift into our ideological echo
chambers because it feels good.
Charisse L’Pree: One of the
arguments I make I was delivered
the faculty address to my to the
incoming class at Syracuse in
2017. I make this argument that
we are not amoebas. But we will
behave like one. So in the mass
will inevitably go in directions
that make them feel better and
away from things that don't make
us feel better. But as humans,
we have that ability. And I
think someone here who is at
Victor ZT Zhang says I'm not
sure if we have free will. We're
just pieces of a complex machine
that seems Facebook and
platforms have our behavior.
Right? The problem is we can't
let it go because of how it
stimulates us, right that we
see.
would never engage with. Because
they because they're
demographically different
because we tend to homogenize
into groups that are similar
with us. But then in these
conversations, they're realizing
about how much similarity they
have. So if anybody wants to
participate, you can go to
charisselepree.me and fill out
the form I think it's right
below the book promotion, scroll
down like the second post or
something. And I would love to
pair you with a student, a media
student and professional media
student who would like to turn
your auto biography Ambar into,
into bite sized media content. I
also was part of a conversation.
I was a consultant for BuzzFeed
and Procter and Gamble, doing
this thing called talk about
bias, where people were paired
with strangers to talk about
bias. And I think the potential
versus the promise versus the
practice of social media is one
where in the potentials we can
engage with anyone around the
world. The promise is we will be
told that our needs will be met.
And the practices we engage with
the people we want to write, but
I think we need to revisit that
potential but the potential
itself is scary. And I will
mention this briefly my
stepfather when he got on
Facebook friended everyone,
everyone. And he was like, I'm
going to talk to the world and I
know people here hearing
everyone, Felix, I'm sorry, if
you're watching everyone. Then
all of a sudden, they start
messaging me with their creepy
messages and they're like, I'm
friends with
Your father and I'm like, dude,
stop.
Unknown: Then he realized that
it's a weird, weird, weird
space. And now he's not on
Facebook anymore. So I think,
you know, we have to, we can use
social media. As I say, as
Victor mentioned in the chat, we
can use social media for our own
needs. And we have to remember
that we can take control. And at
the same time, if we need, like,
start a new Facebook, I have
another Facebook for my cats
that only has 10. Friends, it's
great. You know, like, do with
it what you want. Remember, you
don't have to let Facebook or
Twitter or whichever other
algorithm based platform is
satisfying to define your only
usage. That was a long walk. I
don't remember what the original
question.
Vivek Bald: Right, are there any
we're almost out of time. But I
just want to just see if there
are any other questions out
there.
Charisse L’Pree: I will say
there's a couple in the chats.
And so I'll just hit those roya
apparently a distant relative of
ours work on Romeo and Juliet
and Yiddish. That's cool. I will
say one of our choices on the
Romeo and Juliet, one was only
was American. So there are a lot
that we did not get into it had
to be. So you know, like,
there's literally 200 in our
database, globally. And so we
just had to start cutting things
down. So we cut them down for
American productions or joint
that they had to have American
production. So I look forward to
watching that one.
Amardeep. Again, correct me if
I'm wrong, I come from a decade
of an engineering background and
Media Studies a bit foreign yet
fascinating. During your talk,
you repeatedly thought or purely
thought how I my dad and my four
year old interact with serious
media forums. Loved it awesome.
Absolutely. And like, just how
my book is dedicated to Diane
and Constantine. Diane is my
mother and Constantine is my
son. And the line I say is,
And, and as a last comment, I
find it really interesting the
notion the end of the internet,
I'm an editor based in Mexico
City and one of my collaborators
suggests that the end or limits
of the internet may be where
there is no signal, for example,
in indigenous communities. Yeah,
sure. Do you think critical
thinking may be useful, or which
methodological tools to
integrate them on the internet
from an anti non post colonial
perspective? Well, that is a
conversation for a talk unto
itself. And I hope, Professor
Bald when you do, you'll you'll
bring me in on that conversation
as well.
Unknown: You know, I just I,
participatory media, also
something I learned at MIT, we
have to bring in the people who
were using it to have these
conversations. And so you know,
the only anti colonialist
perspective that involves a
colonized group for grounds and
centered said colonized group,
or previously colonized group, I
should figure out that language
later will correct that post.
And I think that so much coming
back to some of our other points
about media companies mining us
for data, there's something to
be said, there's a.to be
connected with the way in which
we have historically treated
certain groups, mining them for
their resources, mining them for
their labor, mining them for
their land and leaving them
barren. If we start thinking
about this phenomenon across
perspective, across time across
groups, I think that we can
begin to tackle the questions of
today with a more nuanced
approach.
Charisse L’Pree: Ooh, that's
good. Let's close there.
Vivek Bald: That's fantastic.
Thank you so much, Charisse.
Charisse L’Pree: And always,
Andrew brought his. Okay, let's
get
my phone. Let's see here.
Unknown: He's very sweet.
Charisse L’Pree: Here he is.
Unknown: All right.
I'm sorry. This is probably not
a good use of our last minutes
together, but
he had a really good one the
other day.
Charisse L’Pree: Oops in the
potty.
Unknown: I'm sorry. Yeah. So
anyway, yeah, is we're working
on potty training. And I don't
think there's any technology
that helps you with potty
training. That's that's what
we've come. You know what, folks
with potty training m&ms. That's
pretty much it. It's like if
your diapers dry, you get m&ms.
That's all. We're very low tech.
Vivek Bald: Yes.
Okay, well, thank you so much
Charissee
and I look forward to reading
the rest of your book.
Unknown: Thank you so much.
Thank you so much for having me.
I really, really appreciate it.
It was an honor to come home.